let's get started we've been asked to
keep our introductions brief but it's
hard to do that in the case of Balaji
Prabhakar it's it's actually easy to do
he's well known in our community in
Islam some resolution across the range
of theory queuing theory political
gesture my favorite many applications
including incentives in in
transportations and other fields
he's winner of many words he's not just
a star he's a supernova of power field
but it wouldn't this way without logic
thank you thank you David welcome to the
Tuesday session it's on urban systems
but transportation being the focus in
addition to me there are Sid Banerjee
and Devesh boys during talks this
afternoon they're trying to survey the
landscape of topics surrounding
incentives pricing data so most of it is
of course transportation in human beings
but it's also there's enormous interest
in packages these days deliveries
especially of the online purchasing so
there's a bit of that that you'll see in
my talk but I think of it all about
business of public transport
uber lyft type businesses bike sharing
so modern urban mobility I'm gonna talk
about congestion so just to reduce
myself just to give some context until
2008 I was really working on computer
networks that's my field and so for
about six years seven eight years
afterwards I was working on societal
networks some continuously strong
interest for me is a topic which started
in December 2007 when I visited
Bangalore and I believe Everett Arash
was 18 now we had dinner in that
particular year
in that same December do you remember we
were there with PR Kumar and genre sir
some conference is that with it and I'm
sure if you've been to Bangalore you've
seen this you've been in this and one of
these people somewhere is me you know
one of these out-of-body experience
photos this is sort of normal in
Bangalore and it's the sort of thing
that one wants to do something about if
possible and so that's how our started
we were designing large engines now
agents are just a system for
administering nudges in this case paying
money and getting people to shift and
this has been deployed in several places
the first of these was started in
Bangalore with Infosys technology so
don't address the bangle congestion
problem we're trying to see if you can
move Infosys commuters there's about
20,000 of them could you move at you
know enough of them to the off-peak time
for travel paying them some money okay
that's the idea and then the heels of
that project we ended up doing other
ones like Singapore Stanford BART also
used this scheme and then not just for
transportation but also for wellness and
recycling so you'll see how that works
this led us to form a company to supply
the solution to the user so this went
beyond the initial pilot phase and this
is where the transportation companies
are the logistics and delivery type got
involved now opening this is part of
Google Maps they have a ton of maps data
and so that's where sitting for the
presentation I'm going to just focus on
the yellow points briefly describe urban
congestion really you know there are
lots of obviously images but I want to
come up with a cost
because then I want to address that cost
of congestion here in a theoretical
model and then I will briefly describe
the two major components one is to shift
demand the other is to understand supply
and then I'll elaborate on each of those
components so we've all seen or been in
places like this Bangalore or that's
road in Bangalore buses in China this is
the famous Japanese YouTube Willie the
CEO COO train station these are
employees of the train company it's
called Russia and the title the job is
Russia means a passenger arrangement
staff Christ before transmit ok so this
is 100 kilometer long traffic jam single
traffic jam lasted nine days and it
disappeared in three hours so there's an
amazing nine line days they control and
get any remove and then three days just
three hours just disappeared and so so
these are sort of really big problems
and increasingly we're getting into that
sort of mode and it's not there were I
believe it was the the trucks that were
bringing coal from Mongolia in your
Mongolia so there was an it there was a
larger than typical number of them so
this is an example of the small
perturbation systems are now so you know
demand supply so equal and you just miss
a little bit then you you pay for it and
unlike computer networks where the whole
goal is to have roughly ten times the
bandwidth you think you need so no
computer network is allowed to get more
than
wasn't congested typically and the
people are aspiring to 30% in cloud but
that extra slack allows us to have
disappeared protocols or don't
necessarily have to be optimal in urban
systems that kind of slack is
unaffordable so either you have too much
in which case the taxes are going to
kill the people or you're you're always
almost always on the knife edge so
there's some cost to this if you
calculate the extra time and fuel spent
by vehicles stuck in traffic in the u.s.
Texas Transportation Institute puts a
number to that this is the extra time
when fuel not cost or transportation but
the cost of congestion and that's those
numbers it helps to make a dent into
this number by about let's say 20% but
that's meaningful okay one can do it
they published something called urban
mobility reporting to break it down by
region they tell me you how the
calculating this then there's emissions
your the traffic which transportation in
the sector is the second biggest in the
emissions category and then there's also
safety I don't mean just a road
transport you know like just fatalities
but it's of course very bad but even
other things like when you go to subway
systems just the crowdedness demands
that people don't be you know if the
only way you can exit the platform is
the train and then it's the so-called
open platform like New Delhi or London
where there's no barrier between you and
the tracks you have to stop people from
entering the subway station in the first
place okay and London to the Underground
trains stopped before arriving at the
their platform to let the people from
the previous train leave okay so this is
just effects operation itself okay so
this is
important very important so the basic
problem can be you know it's just demand
is much higher than supply and we would
like to work on both sides and one side
reduce demand taking an incentive
approach nor a charging approach both
are up you know can co-exist we are
interested in this from what's the
possibility how much money does it cost
etc perspective and then increase the
supply by understanding where there's
slack in the system often there's slack
in the following way that if you look at
most subway systems in the morning peak
hour almost all the traffic is depth to
the downtown or the business district
and the trains are going back our MT it
is possible to flip one one in three or
one in four trains or some intermediate
station rather than send them all the
way back up the line because it's a
45-minute trip and this is done in many
cities so you can have your supply be
closer to demand that's an example and
but the real problem I'm going to claim
is not so much the supply is exceeding
demand we have a data transportation
architecture and I think that's the one
that the lifts and ubers are all
disrupting and what's classically done
is you know this has been around for
just since the Romans somebody builds
these roads or infrastructure like these
guys some of those guys build these
things or run a bus system in a city or
subway system or a taxi you know company
and then commuters are using them so
basically this is how it is you know the
only place where these two meet is here
okay and so unfortunately this just
doesn't let the supply and demand talk
to each other and what I mean by that is
if you replace this with an app and
abstract this out then whoever's
offering the service directly gets in
touch with with
commuters this is also the model that
Airlines used to use until the mid 80s
they they were the first to get rid of
this model and directly related their
passengers because as airline frequent
flyer programs until then no airline
really knew who was flying necessarily
okay nor do they care to cultivate these
people it's not necessary but now
they're the first ones to have done it
and then now it's hitting the rest of
the you know Road Transport world and if
you think both on the driver side as
well as the passenger side we lift a new
bus because they're keep those both
sides of the equation on the supply and
demand side you know in there that the
the dispatching bout sort of speak okay
so the 21st century thing looks
everything is sort of moved into the
cloud right there's some Apple there you
can offer incentives you get real-time
usage data from the fleet into the
network and you can get user behavior
later when does this person want to
leave where they normally go from what
kind of vehicle do they typically prefer
and then you can offer real-time
analytics and what's happened is
simultaneously several pieces of
technology have fallen in place first we
have this very cheap and ubiquitous
sensors and this terms of bandwidth so
this all won't have been possible even
if we dreamt of it in the pre-internet
pre a smartphone hero it's not possible
so somehow just everything is just right
everybody's got a smartphone and then
there's all the other stuff in the
background so it's sort of you know we
would have had this bad societal
problems if the internet and smartphones
and all hadn't happened for under 50
years all the societal problems would
have been just as bad because nothing
you can even dream of these things but
without this technology you can't do
anything okay
so just as when things start getting bad
luckily for us a parallel network has a
reason to help us
this is not just for moving or people I
claim it's also happening this is
exactly what's happening in commerce in
retail
it's the exclusion of this middle
interface just this has been you know so
in all of the great 20th century
commerce and retail invention is stores
okay
this is a great 20 department stores
chains of departments this is the great
20th century invention anything in the
early 22 2008 century you know all the
barons were chasing up and trying to set
up one of these chain this is like the
Holy Grail and the consumers so these
guys are producing goods just stop these
stores and then we just go here this is
just this is the model for 50 to 70
years this is the model Sears everybody
okay and I was it was great I mean this
allowed a certain you know production of
goods and food especially and the
disbursement of it okay
and a lot of operations research went
into this this portion okay so a way to
allocate stores facilities etc and now
24th century those two sides the
consumers and the producers exist but
everything is just into the cloud and of
course Amazon led the way with lots of
other people doing it but including some
of the stores now have a tremendous
online presence with them often boasting
how much of their revenue is coming from
online the online portion of the
business okay and so so what's happened
is that this listing you list your self
in one of these things and then you buy
online and then there's a home delivery
component okay so this is also very
interesting from a research perspective
it's not settled by any means it's sort
of what are you looking at how to make
maps for at the street level or you're
looking at innovative delivery
mechanisms like drones
and start so this is tremendously
interesting for I would say the next
15-20 years we'll be doing this and then
this is you know Amazon's first you know
an unmanned store opened in Seattle just
last Monday maybe yesterday okay and so
so this is all happening okay so with
that background on like congestion and
you know what's the cost and where was
the work heading let me describe a few
things were large engines
what's a large engine so this is a
landing page for a user anonymized to
Mickey Mouse okay call from the program
we're on our Stanford called Capri this
was aimed at Stanford commuters four
thousand drivers signed up and it ran
for two and a half years was a DoD
funded project to determine if what
happened in Bangalore with Infosys
employees could be replicated here could
that same thing work with a different
social demographic and with a different
mode of transport namely driving
primarily okay so the main elements I
want to focus on there are many things
it one is money so this is a ticker-tape
how many minutes ago or hours ago what
were the winnings it's paid out in
formal lotteries and I'm going to
describe that second is the effect of
friends so what's the effect of money on
your behavior was the effect of friends
on your behavior now finally what's the
effect of personalized office you guys
I'm gonna describe these three things
will give this so feel free to ask me
questions as they come up
okay so the reason I start working on
this is the met this person Praveen
stood in Bangalore 2007 December and he
made this comment there is a willingness
travel a scheme where a new condition
charging and he said this there's a
willingness to pay in Bangalore but
there's no willingness to charge okay so
this is political suicide you don't get
elected you know ken Ken Livingstone in
London did it actually he does his
election platform he did it he got
elected but not again
okay just once okay and so Bloomberg
failed to get it passed out Albany New
York so it's not it's not a popular
thing you know people don't like it and
also in places like Bangalore is very
easy for commuters to say I know where
this congestion look at the roads okay
so first you give me bad roads that
causes congestion then you charge me for
getting rid of this from the new cost
okay so there's a it's not an easy thing
to it's a monopoly system there's only
one set of ropes okay so but there's
there's the question is a really nice to
accept payment so suppose you know we
were to offer money to communities and
would that be interesting so this is the
starting point so how much money would
it take okay so the norm this London's
think charges each certainly charged ten
pounds every time you enter the central
business but the condition Gordon a
started at five and then it increase and
I think it's maybe ten pounds have gone
up but you can't charge ten pound you
can't reward ten pounds for every off
picture of someone makes that's just is
not a sensible thing and to give you an
idea for the do difference project of
Stanford we had a dollar a week per
participant and that dollar a week on
average does the average payment in the
pot so there are four thousand people
there be four thousand dollars in the
pot and that was to be given as 10
there's five morning trips and Fire
evening trips or commuter could make 10
trips in the week and so for each trip
on average there was 10 cents
so 10 sentence I'd like to induce shift
off peak travel in a commuter who's
earning a lot of money okay
certainly 10 senses so now can this be
not that's the question
okay and so also how does one work with
equations like that how does the pot of
money and how does the payment there's a
very interesting set of things we
learned okay
and I think there's some neat outer than
me questions as well there okay so so
this is it so the can we do it yeah this
is maybe backing up a little bit going
into the the willingness to charge I
mean they're in our area there's the
history of gas taxes and and explicit
use taxes for commercial but I mean it's
bubbling up with on your proposal but it
seems to be part of the landscape and so
some commercial news I think there's
easier time scale and that expectation
of maintenance and improvement and
improvement that's different from the
congestion that's right that's the key
point
sir tolls are fine and the Bay Bridge
got done for eight hundred million
dollars redone shock tolls went up okay
the toes are not about congestion either
the label is really the key point gas
tax is similarly under you know it's
sort of there's a slightly higher
penalty that hits people who are stuck
in traffic and burn gas but it is levied
against similar ways like it's just gas
tax anything Oregon does not for example
quite a bit off and so when when you
have to levy a tax there's not directly
a congestion you get away with finishing
charging it's coming here to like there
are some lanes now that are expressly in
high-occupancy toll lanes HOT lanes the
warned day before so California's wheel
and the freeways it's not like that
anymore Washington DC within the past
year
has set up on the Dulles hallway set up
an express lane that people are paying
$40 a day yeah yeah I think it's
happening but it's not been an easy good
thing to push I think the problem is now
so severe that is this willingness to
face going up that's really it what's
going on how many of the people who
travel that way I think they're building
it too you know as a business expense it
will be hard to justify personal expense
about at that level so how does this
lottery thing wha again just sort of
quickly going through things there's
this sort of well known to envelope a
game and it goes like this
it's a store of standard you know a
first lecture in economics or on utility
functions so if you offer that to
envelopes one of them has a
deterministic amount of reward in it
thousand dollars and the other one has
110 thousand dollars was one person
chance and zero dollars of the walls so
on average this pays you $1,100 which
one will you choose actually just can I
just get a show of hands full juice
envelope one versus envelope one okay
who does envelope to Laura someone's
paying a lot of money guys you guys are
like okay wealthy people are the
gambling inste whatever okay so which
one would you pick we've already
answered that but now suppose I offer
the same game where the dollar values
have gone down by a factor thousand okay
who will pick all of one now
I hope pick two okay so you get this
point you can prove it here as well with
concave utility functions you can prove
that even even with that conservative
thing where people are seeking you can
still prove it
in games with low stakes hence lotteries
can matter in these cases we used rather
can make a difference
so let me start with testing this
hypothesis so this is Auto chronological
order because we did this first in
Bangalore in 2008 but I'm going to start
with this it's as part of a Freshman
Seminar of course I thought we had I
think the experiment run because the
Freshman Seminar class
there's no undergrad grad you know grad
class this experiment because it
required students get excited enough to
do this stuff freshmen were great okay
and so in the state of California for
recycling the small cans and bottles you
get five cents and for doing the bigger
ones again ten cents so let's look at
the small ones and we offer the
following to people at Stanford okay so
bring your recyclables and you get to
choose four recyclable which of these
options you want to get paid according
to okay I have the five cent option or
on average five cents with different
odds okay this is just to know how what
was the risk profile it just even tested
hypothesis though I had written previous
life every okay this and so the first
version of this was offered literally
like a lottery in the following sense
this is a MATLAB program this is in fact
the screen itself and you came and you
had let's say five recyclables that gave
you five runs that's what this means
okay see five Kansas bottles and you
said I want to try all of them for the
five dollar option you could do one at a
time with different values but it's
abuse your choice okay and then you
would sort of have a little bit of a
think time when the coins got flipped
with the right bias one in hundred in
this case and you either want something
or you didn't win anything okay
this ran for the first two days in a
nine-day period and thing we noticed was
some people just came and gave the
recyclables and you know phones are just
come out students all had phones and
we're interested in the draw itself we
could of announced the results by
newspaper they just weren't engaged any
further there just me other recyclables
in this
I will show you there's also what they
did okay so we thought that this would
be nicer if we could engage them plus
there's also this thing of how do I know
the odds are what you're claiming they
are okay so second time our third day
with this instead we created a game the
same recyclables five of them that you
came with we let you pick five tiles out
of this hundred so $5 each one is
supposed to be one in hundred odds this
is a ten by ten time grid so the hundred
tiles one of these tiles is a $5 behind
it with your five trials five choices
you get to discover this magic tile oh
you okay this for example we pick the
$20 the odds of that is one in times
four so 400 so - it'll be twenty by
twenty time grid and one of them one of
those tiles is got $20 behind it you'll
get to flip and discover nobody okay
with this the two oceans are not
identical obviously here with five
dollars if you have if you are 100 units
dude for sure win five dollars okay
there you would win it on average okay
so it's it's sampling we're done without
replacement that's the only difference
okay but anyway so this is what we
offered and people will do come on you
know select they will select very
carefully like it matters which would
start you know they would consult with
their friend like it you know okay when
something like this happened not even
disclose but somewhere nearby like you
know the winning tile was here okay so
is this sort of fun there's an emotional
component to the whole thing which
actually was the most interesting aspect
to us now they're engaged it is sort of
interesting
the odds are made completely transparent
it is well known in prospect theory that
the ability that we have for
understanding very small probabilities
this is not that great where this makes
it completely transparent which was
great
there's also many puzzle as to how can I
assure it as sneakily I'm not moving the
tile to some location you didn't pick
right and really want to think of this
puzzle well if you go to a machine and
that offered this thing you could have
the Machine print out its choice and the
paper is already there it's committed
its choice so you'll be verified cost
factor okay there's gonna let you see
the paper after you finish making your
choice in it there's an online version
of this you could do if you're doing it
online
okay but the way it works in practice in
Singapore and all that we have to get
our game license so the Singapore Police
Force you apply send the code they audit
you make sure it's all fair okay as
declared and state of California there
are sweepstakes laws that cover things
like this so Stanford's general counsel
had to sit and look at all this stuff
okay so there are things that are
governing how you do this thinking
anyway so so this is a second version
the other thing we found in addition to
user engagement was simply that for
example what I mean by user engagement
some some student came was doing the $20
option so it's 20 by 20 tile grade and
there are 70 recyclables or so and they
drew a face okay eyes smiley okay so
this is like somebody who just didn't
want to just choose tiles around them
okay so you get the point so in addition
to all this we realize that this is self
administered lotteries and we don't have
to be doing this weekly draw which is
always in Bangalore
because then Bangalore Infosys employees
will write in say I want to opt out or
this week's drop because I'm traveling
on business and I don't want to be
docked you take some amount of points
from your account to be qualified for
the lottery so I don't want to lose the
points because I'm not around okay and I
can't make the points up okay so I'd
like to opt out there's opting out
opting in we just got to be a headache
well this is sort of simpler okay
airline miles programs could do this now
so if it cost 50,000 miles to get a
ticket from here to New York let's say
that could be offered in that way which
is the way it's offered
or they could give it to you for 500
miles but 100 chance ok this so now
average for every hundred persons are
try that option the airline gets 50,000
miles on average and gives one ticket
right it's books about so nitrogen all
of us get lost you know one person super
happy and I know when people are
moderately or hardly unhappy okay yes
there is the notion of some kind of some
trust involved with usually some some
trusted intermediary right so that's
what I was saying about you can commit
your choice in this case or you can
audited so when there's a public entity
or anybody who I talking about just how
do I know you're doing the thing
correctly yeah so that's right so this
is very key I mean this is this is not a
simple step audits are conducted and you
know there's this serious penalties and
you know you get so sometimes these
drawers are conducted in the open that
is you draw a person from the street
pull them in and say pick that thing
from this bowl of possible things and
I'll take down your name and did you do
this this is required by law okay so as
I mentioned so this is key for the
moment we can leave it as how the law
legally is being done but it's a
computer science question as well okay
one of the answers is the one I
mentioned where you commit the choice I
had a time yeah
oh you give this so so what happened was
people did choose as we expected but
somewhat unexpectedly lots of units were
went at the five-cent option but if you
look at the total number of users who
made these choices three people were
responsible for that they actually came
together they apparently go recycle this
is only drink bottled water yeah
Sanford kids okay and so they came they
weekly recycling happens for them and
then they came to your them together and
they just want us to be closer we told
them guys we'll pay you money don't give
us this there's too many things to carry
you know like it's a it's a big bag and
so anyway those were three and LDLs Joe
how they did okay this this does sort of
validate the respeaking sort of behavior
and I think that this was something
again isn't interesting this isn't this
currency note is not heavily in
circulation so I think people have
chosen from the notes that I have an in
circulation in the right odds but is
what we offered okay so that's what I'm
going to tell you about in the first go
about incentives paid through lotteries
administered through games of chance
so for Singapore and and Sanford we
didn't do this game of chance we did
snakes and ladders much easier the
there's into games you sort of realize
there's this thing's called narrative
games are having narratives this is to
episodic this is to episodic I mean it's
just you know the words
you do once and then there's no there's
no progress there's nothing video game
design like this amount of it the only
reason the main work is simply because
you're paying the money whereas if you
have progress and you say oh look you up
on the top of the board people get the
hang of I mean they they like it okay so
we got sponsored by as a you know
research donation by the guys would eat
our hero and they told a number of
different things after the games have
been done they came around and they said
like yeah we see that you got the
elements okay in this sort of snakes and
ladders some there were some tiles that
had extra bonus payments and you know
like various things and they said oh
that's called Easter Egg you have to
have an easter egg in games in every
level and then you have to have levels
and people do what's called level
grinding this whole thing is apparently
well-known okay there's a whole science
on how to get people to play games that
stay engaged okay so we just happen to
hit on some things and we learned after
we spoke to them and then start doing
this deliberately okay okay so that's
what I'm going to tell you some
questions or comments
do you account for bringing effects when
usually slightly like somebody who's
wealthy might hard to be willing to
spend time even clicking and I agree no
we didn't we didn't wynant
they wouldn't have questionnaires and
stuff like that first of all when we
were doing this I didn't even realize
that we're gonna have people what you
know as many people as these come and I
don't think they're all the student the
class students as friends
they're just random people in fact we
hand out outdoors near the dorms and
someone would see his and walking away
from walking back from lunch or
something say let me bring some recycled
stuff in their plate and see what
happens she was bought more that way but
they're all stand for students but gives
you a more or less okay gives you a
certain base
so there is some novelty attached with
doing this way so is there a way to
separate out and nobility aspect of it
and like the long term yeah yeah so
that's what I'm gonna summarize
everything by showing the Singapore
project but had has the analysis is for
five years so to your point since people
may not come to play the game but
there's not exactly you know the top of
your mind you know us unless some friend
of yours in this in things like the
snakes and ladders not only is your
piece moving but you get to see your
friends as pieces okay well when we when
we design it that way which is a
question um extra work but so now people
have a reason to come because your
friend wants some prize and then you
know it's like that okay that is you get
these notifications but I'll show you
how but what we did was to not have to
worry about this we had a weekly
autoplay option so whatever points
balance was in your account you could
choose to autoplay them and the system
would just play them for you thanks Ron
and onion but I saw you presented a year
and a half ago the world could be run on
Pokemon
everyone is obsessed with Pokemon and
you know it's just incredible and people
excited about because they were together
and that's scary yeah this is bit of a
novelty affecting so the thing here is
that people have to commute right so the
the most important thing is look at all
the projects we picked we didn't stick
with recycling too much because you
don't have to recycle okay it is one of
the things as academics worthwhile take
projects that you know you have to
commute you have to take a shower
hopefully
so in other words we do water
conservation that's a good project okay
I just measure the flow and the
temperature the water using and then not
you to do the right thing but that's an
example right you essentially have to
walk you don't have to undertake
physical exercise like go to the gym
that's harder but how about the step
tacular project is to get you to walk a
little bit more right so if you go after
the necessary activities that we do and
then just not stop that's much easier
you have to eat okay and it has to be
frequent it's not something like buying
a car which is once in a while no point
in lunging there's nothing large there's
an interesting socio-economic dichotomy
here in that if you impose a huge toll
for the privilege of using an express
lane that appeals to one particular
segment of people those who have money
to burn small payments of a nickel for
recycling the bottle tend to engage the
other is there any way we can get
everybody know I think maybe maybe the
thing you're saying is that I can so you
charge those are willing to pay so apply
congestion charging duck for those who
must go in the peak hour and can't
afford to pay for it now for those who
don't want to do it out because too
expensive reward them so the two can
coexist okay
it's a bit of a like a Robin Hood system
okay let me continue because I have a
few more things to say and then I'll
come back to questions of the year
social influence okay this was a
immediately obvious to us but there's a
lot of social psychology literature on
this this aspect there's also booked by
Robert Cialdini called influence which
is surprisingly used by a lot of people
do marketing okay somehow it's like you
know you talk to marketing possess
digital child in his book okay it's like
it's like
papademetriou on one of those kind of
you all read these books right so okay
so the effect of friend so friends can
play two really important roles one in
recruitment they're gaining entry you
know it's like free
Marketing and second is to help with
behavior shifting so let me show you the
first thing recruitment January 10 2012
we launched this program in Singapore in
sync it stands for incentives for
Singapore's commuters it's now called
travel smart rewards program and so in
case you want to go look for it I'm
still going on okay there were nine
newspapers in this press release night
okay so they're like English language
Mandarin Malay Tamil they're all their
TV stations from all the languages all
the major ones radio guys already was
that I thought this is the whole island
is heard at this cannot be anybody that
has not heard about this okay completely
wrong he just doesn't didn't we only had
three thousand people signed up at the
end of the month okay but there were
some things like you know press just
fell off after the you know first bursts
there's nothing keeping us in the news
Chinese New Year came when people of
course you know a reason sir do their
own thing our February 14th Valentine's
Day so we did recommend a friend system
so this is just to link to your web
account was Facebook Connect and Google
Yahoo Connect so you could just invite
your Facebook Google Yahoo friends and
if you did that for every friend that
you recommended that are not joining and
we could we had sort of ways where if I
were fine they just carried a token
imported back right you got 250 points
250 points is 25 cents in monetary terms
and it represents one week worth of
commuting 150 kilometers okay so you see
that the dollar value is so small but
then when you survey people they think
of how long it takes to earn those so 50
points okay so we found this is a nice
way of representing it okay and they
joined so here's how it went
so signups went increase right away and
then the percentage of users as of the
dates that had joined because of friends
here okay
as soon enough across 90% okay
so almost all of this came from and the
user acquisition cost is just 25 cents
as if you ask Facebook or Google or
Amazon what they're willing to pay it's
somewhere in the ten to twenty dollar
range
maybe more I'm sure lyft and uber will
probably pay more maybe in the $40 range
okay so it's not an easy thing to do but
again people have to commute this is not
working it's like I'm not gonna induce
you to go to Amazon and buy something
but that's not what I'm doing here okay
so I'm gonna say there's more to say
about recruitment Blom I'm gonna move on
to what's the effect of friends on one's
behavior the blue line for this program
spectacular this is the idea was you
Accenture and USA employee signed on and
the reward money was $2.00 per signed on
person per week and the more step they
walked the more points they got and this
is measured through a pedometer which
they are used to upload their steps to
the site this is what happened okay
those this is the average number of
steps taken by participants during each
week in the program this is the steps
taken by those without friends within
the program okay so this is about a yeah
this is increased over time and this is
the number of steps taken by people with
friends so numerically you can see how
many the number of friends you had as it
increased you tend to take more steps on
average this has been a fairly constant
invariant in every yes so you don't know
if this is causational or just you're
more likely to connect with your friends
on this if you
actually were active in the program so
we in this case we didn't have this from
day one we launched it about a month
into the program okay so we had their
behavior before their friends and then
I'm showing just a portion and had
friends thinking again people are more
social so there this is a there's a
particular answer we give in the paper
to that question it's not directly in
furball but we demonstrate i can tell
you more offline that the friends are
actually causing in this case because of
the before/after data as well as an
argument that separates out the
propensity for people pretend to be more
social to sign up sign on the french but
also those people may tend to walk more
just to begin with okay it's not
conclusive but there's something else
that is more conclusive which is this
one the probability that i user will
stick to the program several people lost
their pedometers okay these are not you
know turbines $30 we nah me to
accidentally reimbursed you for it but
you buddy had to buy it
and unfortunately about a dozen of thus
often lost maybe two dozen and lost this
pedometer although the 3,000 or people
who happy no meters but when they were
friended they weren't bottoms of the
pedometer that's just more some more
clear evidence for nudge them and then
they okay but this one is again what's
the probability we'll stick with the
program as you continue to walk and
register europe you know behavior okay
but it's also something as well known in
these friends not appreciated meaning we
don't tend to credit our friends even
though there may be the friends have an
effect on you when surveyed of course we
are the reason why we're doing good
things okay this is septic laser what is
the reason that most encouraging check
all that apply
you know selling gold you know this is
the
comparing my and some other friends are
just like you know why did he join the
program there are other questions too
okay and so even when they came in
through a friend recommendation they're
less likely to credit it this is
actually in known and Charlie knee
Charlie knee worked with or Power guys
unless another social norming sort of
energy thing that was very popular so
important by Oracle it was observed
there in a similar way but with
different measurements okay
so here's another NSYNC Zoey I see my
friends doing it inspires me as I say
tons of 90% of people join the program
because of the friends no credit not not
much okay okay so I don't have a lot of
data to show you a person has offered
but by far this was the biggest of the
three things in terms of making the
dollars apply correctly so what I mean
by that is incentive program suffer from
the adverse selection problem meaning
that those who are most likely to
exhibit the correct behavior will join
the program first because one thing is
to say I do I've learned about this
program because my trans dovey and
probably many of them would say yes I
did it oh but we don't do really things
because my friends surveys are carefully
constructed and then there's the a/b
testing way of asking a question a here
and slightly different question there
and so on and then we large enough
population even though you don't ask the
same person looking at a comparison we
didn't end up doing that these things
you get a week's time to get the survey
up and going so it's sort of most of the
effort here was spent like just you know
the automated response to this is not
working and you know how many points of
my earning again and what happened to my
units like that so there's a lot of
administrator had that hit us which was
surprising but but you're actually like
we didn't also you know in runtime sort
of speak some of these things we didn't
even know
but you're right okay so adverse
selection
Accenture the first few people signed up
to this program were the marathon
runners okay
of course they're you know that's what
that's what's gonna sign to me
it's system meant to walk more and so
because of this many incentive programs
have the worry that the money that's
being spent is inducing a lot less
behavior shift and desired so this
metric called dollars per shift that is
important okay personalized offers allow
you to do this because you can target
people who aren't shifting the behavior
adequately and then give them extra you
know sort of 50 or 100 points more for
making trips in the off-peak time or
whenever it is desired
okay and it also encourages participants
to visit so this could also be what I
mean where behavioral is I found that
David doesn't like to travel in the
off-peak time of Mondays and Wednesdays
because he has an early morning class
and he has to be there on whatever it is
he's got his reasons but if I ask him on
Tuesday and Thursday evenings he's
always willing to go off-peak so I've
learned that that's the case that's what
I mean so you can learn specifically and
that he costs a lot less compared to
David Moyes for example okay so it's
like you know he loose on same behavior
for like 20 points and he David wants
two other points so you know that's what
I mean okay so that's how we can decide
these things and then we were nudging
accordingly this is probably the moon
you know there's a bunch of things here
that he did about at least a dozen of
these and they were really very
informative yeah I think it did was we
found an engaged participant just
plainly the more times you visit the
side the more your behavior shift that's
just a business bound
so I'm gonna conclude this whole thing
by showing you how all this comes
together in one project with the
long-running Singapore project is
countries runs you now we launched it
for a six month university trial and
then it got taken over by urban engines
as a an offering or a program by summer
2016
it was called the travel smart reward
program by then and then there were at
least 400,000 people signed on plus 70
or more company so companies could join
the program and enrich the pot for
example listening you know something
that was done by Bart as well as the
program in Singapore and you could join
you know as a corporate member and so
your employees join together and so this
was stages of the program and then the
overall shift I'm going to show you more
details was at least 10% okay so the
program itself was you travel with your
smart card we saw your where you entered
and where you exited that give us a
distance and for every kilometer you
travel you got a point if the trip
happens to be in the off-peak time when
you trip then you've got three or more
points per kilometer okay exactly like
an airline miles program with an
off-peak bonus is it okay then you could
go to your website and you could look at
your history of rewards like think of
United Airlines or whatever your airline
program is miles and then you could go
and redeem this for cash or sometimes
in-kind rewards for example Stanford
needs to get football tickets
other thing of like getting latching
your program on to something that's
local that everybody knows so you don't
have to get free advertisement
it's called trend jacking okay trend
jacking is like they don't allow it so
we also try to do this with FIFA World
Cup because you know if your favorite if
you had a hero team on a villain team
when your hero team wins you'll get
three times the points on that day for
your trips off big trips and your
winning team loses you get three times
the points okay you come branded a FIFA
FIFA it's just like there it is will
descend on you like a ton of bricks so
you don't mention free for anybody
nothing is just I'm just uh you know
okay so so you get the point that it's
amazing with already watching this is
sort of in the consciousness okay so
what happened and for the first six
months
let me wrote a paper on this so that's
available on my website if you look at
people so you'll see numbers like this
this is
this is a 5:00 a.m. 12:00 noon and what
fraction of commuters were traveling in
what five minute segments the PDF okay
the blue is the before so we have three
months of commuting history for a person
before they join the program up to three
months okay and then the orange is d
after okay so this seven
sorry eight to nine was the peak hour so
the goal is to avoid this and you got
your three times or the extra points in
the orange zones okay this is where you
got an extra boost
if you travel really early or after this
time you just got the one X you didn't
get the extra boost let me give this
what's going on so the goal is to try
and move people away from the peak and
this is how it worked
this chart shows how it is for all the
commuters this includes the people who
are already traveling in the off peak
hour okay of which there are at least
twenty twenty-five percent this is for
those who only travel in peak - made at
least five peak time trips before they
join the program okay this is a subset
of all users the subset being the ones
that travel at least me at least five
peak trips so the mildly traveled in the
peak hour before the joint so for
hundreds more to shift and this is at
least ten big trips before and at least
20 pictures before joining so mildly in
the peak medium in the peak and heavy
legally okay so in general they just
have more shift there's moral you know
you're you can expect more shifting okay
and so yeah the fact on the very first
part there's a bunch of people go just
to get the reward like you know you
don't want a small bump Ian yeah top 10
seconds before when you start giving
them reward and that shift isn't like
maybe a TV that's right so you can zoom
in if you zoom in you can see it here
too this is almost like that's right so
there's a much better explanation of
this in the Stanford program and the
reason is so many of these guys the ones
who were traveling heavily in the peak
were usually if you look at where they
were traveling they were traveling near
the edges so we didn't end up so when we
look at the the non heavy peak time
travelers and everybody else there's a
bit more you know this is the peak here
is more pronounced so this is this is
the propensity for people to try on the
peak who responded to this program were
there was one so basically one had to
shift only 15 minutes or so roughly okay
and they ended up in general traveling
in the peak more here and they were able
to shift but we didn't have this kind of
pronounced effect in general when you're
zooming you do see a little small little
bit it's just too small to observe also
this is the number of commuters in this
category is 36% of all commuters okay by
the time you come here is only 19
percent but then you ask how many peak
trips are contributed by these guys but
is 19 percent it's a nexus already so
this is 95 percent this is about 75
percent so small number of people make
the majority the peak time trips what is
that thing to you think these are just
morning trips
okay so you're gonna see these kind of
phone numbers but according categories
now like those who play the game those
without with friends in the program
those without friends those who play the
game those just opted for the fixed
exchange 25 cents or what want one
dollar equals thousand points that's
what I mean the fixed exchange
okay short distance long distance etc
okay now the all in the groove excused
these numbers because the only group
includes all the people who are
travelling in the off off-peak even
quite a bit before they joined the
program and it's just especially in the
distance category this was short
distance commuters are predominately
traveling in the peak time because they
don't have long distance together they
don't have to end your horrible
congestion for too long then really care
that only went three or four stations
long distance companies are typically
already you know trying to avoid the
peak out so that there was some skew in
this whole thing which we remarked about
in minerals thesis but this is summary
numbers all a mild medium heavy okay
this is just for six months and then as
you look across the years this is again
all at least five and so on but the
thing is this got the normed to what
happened to their behavior some of them
before they join the program altogether
right so there's some real oming over
time would be good also system itself
was adding more lines so it wasn't the
same system okay
people had other routes to take what
happened was luckily for such an it such
an opportunity arose when the government
wanted to change the peak from an hour
to an hour and a half and so now you
have this thing of lamb turning up this
is already I already did this and I'm
going to give up
I'm just staying the peak or I'm gonna
adjust to the new peak and shift out of
the new peak okay this was an
interesting that's great I mean
experiment respect is great news like
he's my degree higher system-wide change
okay
I'm just going to show you the summary
numbers but there's more in the write up
the the key point is that against the
new metric everything drops just because
you're still measuring according the
behavior was according the previous
thing so it all drops immediately but it
picks up again and often either a person
was going to make the effort and change
or not and this was decided in the
two-week period this is in two weeks
they don't change they do don't they
roughly never gonna change with a high
chance eighty-five percent okay so
that's interesting because you know it's
sort of we found this you know we had
categories like newbies was sometimes
people don't understand rules like what
is the peak hour you know it's not
obvious and so you know when we're on
serve is checking on this people often
they know what the peak hour was okay so
let me go to just two slides and I'm
down okay
those with friends similar to the thing
before no friends
one friend two friends etc okay the
trend here is again the more friends you
have the more you tend it to travel in
the off-peak okay over time this is
something interesting because does it
actually promote loyalty to the public
transit use itself because you have the
option of taking car or some other motor
transport you know in airline miles
programs it's known that people once you
have a number like you know miles earned
people always try to make that bigger
okay
every is mileage runs probably heard
this I have to go to this meeting in
Europe for my business meeting and
there's necessary and then you'll
approve because you're on the border are
you in a bump up okay this happens but
what about public transit because
everyday behavior okay so the
expectation freaks you already think
that it's going to happen you be
surprised if we didn't what the question
is what's the extent so if you look at
people or joined and the weeks before
they join
we're looking at people who made only
zero to two trips at all not peek just
trips at all in the public transit
system this is nothing to the peak it's
just pure trips at all and this is the
overall population of all users you're
all population all users makes about
three and a half morning peak trips this
we're looking at people who made zero to
two this is their average number and
this is to this two and a half years was
one and a half down there okay
after the join he goes up closer to two
and a half from one and a half just
roughly about you know 60 to 70 percent
increase okay
and so and this was stable it went there
and stuck okay the same thing for
distance as well not surprisingly this
was more about which type of communities
are doing the short short distance or
long distance ones and I didn't include
that chart here so those are all the
things there's more to say or the capri
program or how what do you do when you
don't know that before behavior is and
how do you compare and things like this
so I will stop here however take any
questions you may have or we can go to
the break and come back and
take maybe few questions and then
continue what population combined under
so what is that Vantage of this type of
incentive scheme over just variable
pricing it's the can you pass that it's
it's a question of the when you put it
to the vote it's not been very popular
many places have tried but not been
successful okay
in the u.s. we've got rounded by having
one lane not the entire highway okay
that's the thing can you Institute it
more than anything else it's possible
over time more cities will find it
necessary to do it but that's the main
issue there's you know it's not versus
it's not advantageous to complementary
ways of doing it
listen Singapore if you drive your car
told you pay changes over time yeah so
this started in 1975 okay
I met the Minister of Transport up from
the time Union home he made a very
interesting comment he said that what
the press you know when they relaunched
it with an electronic version not the
original you know previously police used
to write down your license plate and
there's that there's pictures of that on
the mid-80s they were the electronic
version with gantries and stuff I used
to get these questions about like the
the often the press says you're
intruding on my privacy citizens are
like not happy because it's like you're
charging me more okay in fact it's
called electronic road pricing and the
government knows and people say it's ERP
stands for every day wrong people okay
so it obviously just has a negative
effect people don't like it okay
but it's necessary the place is too
small and you know in a hostile and they
also regulate car ownership itself right
so there's very different issues in
Singapore places Singapore Hong Kong and
Manhattan are very particular they're
all basically the small island like
things and then
everything is different okay but
continuing on that he made this comment
which he said if he had the incentive
option he would have done both because
if I said he told me it felt like a two
hundred basketball player not just
pricing he felt like one I thought was a
colorful thing to say but anyway you get
the point it is another to know the
times so he's referring to something
where before we started the mass rapid
transit system had a flat first it's our
30 cents you you get a flat 30 cents
reward no lottery nothing
if you leave block you know there's that
and then it's over time they also did
the free version of it okay apply to
some stations not island-wide okay and
you exit there's some differences we
were in two hours arrival time so this
has been heavily compared and contrasted
for that reason okay this costs a lot
less because of the lottery thing and so
they have different effects basically
yeah maybe one last question and then
let's continue offline good good going
back to your statement of well you have
to commute we go back about 15 years
telecommuting was was going to shave off
this five to ten percent and
and so what what happened to how did
that hypercycle
work out so I'm glad you're asking the
question and I think this is probably
the most important question I've worked
on this for eight years now and now that
is Evelyn is acquired by Google Maps and
I'm out of it in the formal sense this
problem still exists right that's why
it's here okay I don't think the future
of encumber bility is zero commuting
that's what I think okay I said this and
it wasn't very popular but I think
that's that's the answer okay and it's
not popular in the valley because people
like to you know how employees in the
workplace because the improves
productivity etcetera but I think that's
just a an artifact of our current
technology for distance interaction yeah
I know the reason I'm saying is because
I had there was a there's a no time I
wrote for a class the cost of moving a
person is like this cost of moving a bit
is like this it's obvious that you're
gonna move this people movement a bit
movement just because the cost is the
problem is the tools aren't up there yet
so I had an undergrad student do a an
audit of Stanford commuters on the daily
commute basis as well as the trips we
take for conferences and in fact create
a carbon footprint measurement for
conferences like we have people from far
away places but isn't this is a good one
because we were here for five months so
we're on the right place guys okay we do
a lot of flyby one session conference
with it okay all the way to DC for one
session and then go home this is like a
trend if you ordered the conference for
footprint and see that number is very
discouraging and there's no reason why
we can't just have presentations online
okay and I think that's probably gonna
happen in five years conferences first I
believe I think I can demux make a huge
difference there
let's take a coffee break
[Applause]